fun fact you can mix and match these
boundaries just like we missed it mix
and match them here within a quiz let's
put something in for range so so if I
said for example something like this
okay now in many circumstances when
we're describing range or domain we can
never get to the actual boundary you can
get really really close but you can't
actually get there can someone give me
an example what kinds of graphs when
you're talking about their domain or
range do you get close to a thing but
you never quite get there can ya Zack
you reckon if there's an asymptote and
an example of where there's an asymptote
is the exponential function now you
don't have to draw this but just for the
sake of your arm of your visuals right
when you think about next financial it
looks something like this you got that
asymptote this right there on the x-axis
right so you can get like real close to
zero but you never actually touch right
so that's why we have to of course
exclude this guy now if I were to draw
that onto a number line like so if this
is a y number line and so next one
I want my zero I want to and of course
I'm just going to include one of them
being open and one of them being closed
as appropriate so here this is the one
that's open and then the other one is
closed it's filled up and I draw it just
like before now how are we going to use
our interval notation for this file
first thing don't forget this is range
so I'm not gonna write X I'm gonna write
Y very good it just corresponds to
whatever values it'll be belonged to
what okay you go ahead yep yeah very
good normal at the beginning they are
called parentheses by the way that's the
proper name and then a square one at the
end so square bracket and then we're
just going to include our numbers just
like before okay now see how we had a
closed interval and then we had an open
interval well kind of like half of its
open and the other half not so this is
really original right they call this a
half open interval
sometimes the naming is really
imaginative okay now this next one right
I'm going to draw it first and then I'm
gonna ask you to help me
state the inequality and then we'll work
out the interval notation together so
here's what I'm going to draw and it's a
very simple one let's leave this in wise
just to shake things up I'm gonna go
like this
that's call this one okay so this isn't
wise right I'm gonna have a Y over here
there's going to be a Y somewhere
what inequality would correspond to this
particular number line y is greater than
or equal to one how did you know it was
included yeah it's filled very good okay
now when I write this next part we can
help we can do quite a bit of this right
we know that it belongs to what
pronumeral it's why we write that funky
little epsilon right is it going to be a
parenthesis or a square bracket to begin
with be a square bracket because I'm
included we know we started one but then
you like where's the nd okay so there's
no number that you can put in here
because otherwise that would mean
there's no arrow that it would stop
somewhere right so there isn't a number
you can put there but there is a concept
there is an important idea it just goes
on forever
we have a special mathematical word for
forever right starts with an i infinity
thank you so it's our sideways eight all
right now it's very important we know
right this is not a number infinity is
not a number you can like put into
something in fact it's it's essential
it's not none because I'd like you to
stop somewhere right this guy never
stops now because it's never a number
can you ever reach there the answer is
no so should I put a square bracket or a
parenthesis it never stops
you never get there right so therefore
you're gonna use one of these guys right
one of these parenthesis because you
never arrive at infinity it's not closed
right so you can't ever say I'm equal to
that okay I won't write it as an example
but you of course could have it the
other way around right what if I wrote
this maybe I will if I wrote this mmm
whoops oh yeah that's fine that's okay
what would this mean
so Alex yeah yeah I'm like starting
starting all the way over there as far
as even further than you could possibly
go and then where do you end yeah ah so
that's another way to say it right
you're like oh this is a number start
with this guy cuz I at least know where
numbers are right maybe for completeness
sake we should draw it since that was a
good conversation to have
so mmm here's my zero because I think
zeroes are pretty important on there to
have on the number line
he is negative three Andres is
suggesting we start using that as our
reference point because you're like I
knew where that is should I draw a
filled circle or a whole edge circle
this one's this one is hollow is not a
solid because the boundaries are
excluded right so I'll draw my hollow
one there and then it's like just just
go for it just go for down go down never
never come back sorry buddy
just keep on going okay yeah oh that's a
great question
actually I think that's what I probably
should have written off it's probably I
should written the first time so even
though it's a bit funny it's not a
number right infinity can actually go in
both directions we know this from our
Cartesian plane right it's different to
get up than just to go down should have
written that the first time in fact I'm
gonna just clean that up so you can
write a proper negative sign in there
thank you for picking that up that's
more like it
okay are you happy with that is that all
right hmm don't miss anything mrs. Luce
it's pretty complete oh yeah sure thanks
very what am I gonna put here so this is
about Nexus right what are we gonna say
that completes this yeah small then
lesser than negative three and it goes
all the way forever